hey everyone just a quick video to let
you know that I recently did some
voiceover work with you me lad on their
coverage of Celebrity Big Brother in
case you didn't know I'm from Newcastle
and they wanted a guy who could do a bit
who could do a bit of Julie Luke I'm
sorry that was terrible anyway here's a
clip from their coverage Axl embalm
thinks T of you in a house to rent but
they soon realize which house they are
actually so make sure you go check that
full video out linked in the description
and I just want to thank all of you guys
for your support over the last year it's
been absolutely incredible or what your
channel grow and your continued support
helps me to get put forward for things
like this
so I really appreciate it and thank you
also bit bit of spam here make sure you
check out my Nick Fury fan Theory video
at the end of this one which discusses
why Nick Fury has taken all this time to
call Captain Marvel so make sure you
check that out and thanks for watching
this video as well you're beautiful take
care peace
[Music]